notre jugement a été altéré par notre
volonté de donner à Sandro grande une
deuxième chance
force d'admettre aujourd'hui que ce fut
une erreur le CF Montréal était au
courant mais a choisi de réhabiliter
Sandro grande des l'équipe Celeste
convaincre par sa maturité acquise dans
les dernières années ainsi que la teneur
de son CV point de vue que ce soit
technique point de vue développement
avec les jeunes point de vue
commentaires des parents qui avaient
aucun problème de de d'envoyer leur
enfant avec avec Sandro la nomination de
grandehi unanime et entérinée par Joey
Saputo a été annoncé hier mais le
principal intéressé a été congé dit
presque au même moment des commentaires
haineux fait dans le passé lui ont coûté
son poste après l'attentat du Métropolis
en 2012 il a notamment partagé ceci le
tireur a manqué sa cible faisant
référence à Pauline Marois qui en est
toujours bouleversé cela matin je dirais
quasiment plus que lorsque c'est arrivé
à tel indiqué au soleil
le club
en s'excusant d'avoir manqué de
sensibilité cette volte face a notamment
été saluée par François Legault pour qui
cette histoire appelle toute
l'importance de ne pas banaliser
l'attentat politique de 2012 moi ce que
je dis c'est qu'on a une responsabilité
comme société et je pense que c'était le
geste à poser les commentaires de grande
idée et la décision du club de soccer
ont suscité une avalanche de réaction
c'est un encouragement à une tentative
de meurtre donc une incitation publique
à la haine la soirée la plus importante
de sa vie lui a été volé par un attentat
politique et par la suite on a un homme
monsieur grandi qui s'enfer l'éloge de
tout ça pour Valérie plante la haine le
racisme et la misogynie n'ont pas leur
place elle espère que le club continuera
d'incarner les valeurs de respect et
d'inclusion
et oui le président du CF à vous avoir
été surpris par l'ampleur du
mécontentement une vague qui était
pourtant prévisible selon certains ici
et mets le mieux Radio-Canada Montréal